I've always done writing as part of
everything that I've done in the past.
Just various creative enterprises.
I write songs and do music and uh,
write essays and short plays and sketch
comedy and all these things.
And there during my twenties,
I was living in Chicago and probably
pursuing everything creatively that I
can think of all at once and waiting for
something to choose me.
Um,
I got a job right out of graduate school
working for a local television show in,
in Chicago.
And so I was doing writing for that,
but I was also writing music and I was
doing a little bit of performing.
Um,
uh,
I was writing plays and,
and also performing on stage and doing
the music thing and playing coffee
houses and Blues Clubs.
Um,
and ultimately,
uh,
I was just waiting for something to
choose me.
And what happened was somebody
suggested,
well,
why don't you write a screenplay for a
movie?
And I thought,
well,
I like movies.
And so I wrote one and,
and I looked at it and said,
that was fun.
Um,
I didn't like that particular screen
plane,
didn't do anything with it,
but then I wrote another one and send it
out and somebody bought it and all of a
sudden I was a screenwriter and I
thought that was easy.
I'll do this.
Um,
and so I just kept doing it and I
haven't had any reason to do anything
else since.
Good.
That good part.
Writing a screenplay is not so hard.
That's all about knowing where the
margins are.
Fighting a good screenplay is almost
impossible.
I think it's part of,
it has to do with,
um,
being original,
trying to do something that feels fresh
when there've been so many movies made
and,
and also particularly in Hollywood,
a tendency to try and remake the same
movies over and over again.
So it's writing a movie that's original,
um,
that becomes really difficult.
Uh,
and
there's something very formal about the
enterprise of writing a screenplay.
It can't be longer than two hours.
Um,
so the kind of story you tell,
whatever it is,
it has to be as engaging and as exciting
as possible within that one and a half
to two hour period.
And that forces certain kinds of
conventions on you or places where,
oh,
we really want to have them gripped in
the story by here or else they're going
to leave or change the channel or,
or walk out of the theater.
Um,
there's a certain kind of efficiency
built into screenwriting that's,
that's very elegant,
but that makes it as hard to craft as a
very finely crafted piece of sculpture
or furniture or something like that.
Uh,
um,
and,
and making it all come alive when you
just start putting together all the
pieces of things that you visualize,
that would be wonderful.
Um,
it all seems in your mind to be
wonderful.
But then what,
when you look at what you've created on
the page,
it's like a Frankenstein's monster.
You've got a head,
you've got the hands,
you've got the feet,
you've got the body,
you thought of everything.
And when you look at it and it's still
just a bunch of dead meat lion there on
the table and you're trying to get a
pulse to go through the thing,
what makes it real?
It's a complete artifice.
It's completely made up.
It's all these things from your head and
your desires and dreams and you know,
it,
it isn't real yet.
And somehow something has to spark off
the page that makes you to,
to join the life that's going on in this
world that you've created.
And to make that smooth life feel real
when the whole thing is artifice.
It all has agenda.
It's all people you've created and
worlds that don't even exist.
Um,
making that feel real,
that's,
that's the absolute impossible thing.
Being original,
making it feel real and making it all
fit.
Uh,
it's,
it's the easiest thing in the world and
it's absolutely impossible.
Um,
a screenwriting is an art form,
but it's also a craft.
It's both of those things.
It's a commercial art.
Um,
um,
and both of those things you need to be
good at.
I,
uh,
if you just know the craft and you don't
have any sense of the art,
that means you don't have anything to
say.
And you don't have an interesting way to
say it.
If it's all art and no craft,
then you've got these great ideas,
but you aren't able to articulate them
in a way that makes it all work out as a
good blueprint for building a great
movie.
So I definitely think there's,
there's a great deal of artistry
involved.
I've never seen a good screenplay that
was nothing but craft.